jean marc maillot donc né le 22 novembre
51 donc ça veut dire 64 ans donc dans
quelques jours je suis né à chambon donc
saint-andré et donc je suis
vice-président donc de la ligue réunion
sport adapté membres d'associations donc
représentant les personnes handicapées
dans les collectivités et président
d'anglo spécial hollande
le sport déjà en main des valeurs de
confiance en soi donc de valorisation de
la personne et c'est plus qu'important
que ces personnes puissent pratiquer une
activité où elles prennent plaisir et
que prennent plaisir donc de partager
d'être avec les autres de montrer leurs
capacités
parce que bien bien trop souvent on les
croise dans le dans le milieu on regarde
disant abeilles sont pas capables et
nous nous croyons c'est un concept que
nous ne défendons le haut niveau du
sport adapté
il s'occupe de nous des ascione moi
c'est plutôt un bon casse on investit
beaucoup
il n'a pas une minute à lessive ou
pourquoi pas écrire
voilà il est toujours disponible pour
les hommes je trouve que les jeunes
attendent une récompense mais enfin si
on lui donne c'est pas moi
cette richesse qui m'ont donné un donc
du plus petit au plus grand donc c'est
une richesse que je finirais ma vie pour
son pouvoir le rendre parce que
justement ils m'ont donné temps